voters across germany are casting their
votes in a national election that will
decide who succeeds angela merkel as
chancellor it is one of the most
uncertain german elections in living
memory with opinion polls too close to
call
now many germans have left their
decision of which party to vote for
until the very last moment others have
already made their choice via postal
ballot the latest opinion polls show the
center-left social democrats with a
slight lead over merkel's conservative
christian democrats meanwhile the
environment-focused green party is
expected to come third but could play a
decisive role in forming a coalition
and we can cross straight to our
political correspondent nina harza who's
outside the chancellor uh chancellory
angela merkel's office nina thanks for
joining us it is a big day here in
germany can you give us a sense of how
people are feeling
well this has been an extremely
turbulent dynamic election campaign that
was dominated by
rising and sinking poles for the main
contenders in this race to succeed
angela merkel of course there are three
hopefuls that do want to move into this
office behind me the chancellery but
here in germany we elect parties and so
the parties um have had an economic race
especially the social democrats and the
conservatives and of course um it is an
extremely un
conventional and very very interesting
election campaign because of two reasons
one the incumbent chancellor is not
running again usually we vote our
chancellors out of office or they have
to resign because of scandals but this
time around angela merkel just chose
that she wants to hand over the job to
somebody else and then secondly there is
no clear successor and no party will be
able to go it alone so they will all
depend on coalitions and there are
currently as many as six coalition
options on the table that are fairly
realistic so it will come down to
watching how the smaller parties fare
tonight at 6 pm when the results come in
to find out to get a hint of who might
move into this office behind me
nina as you mentioned the massive thing
about this election is that it's the
first time in 16 years that angela
merkel
is not one of the the candidates for
chancellor how much would you say will
she be missed
it is interesting because of course
angela merkel is um extremely well known
she is almost already a historic figure
but she uh here in germany the picture
is divided now she is by far the most
popular politician
64 percent of germans in a recent poll
said that they were happy or ex or very
happy with how she's doing her job but
then there was another poll that said
that 52 percent of germans say that they
will not miss angela merkel as
chancellor and you can understand that
after 16 years of somebody in office it
is time for change the younger people
don't know anybody else than angela
merkel and so it is possibly time for a
new government now when we uh look back
at this campaign what have the what are
the biggest moments been for you
this was a campaign where there were ups
and downs for all the three main
candidates all the chancellor candidates
that were officially put forward by
their parties from the conservatives the
social democrats and from the greens and
every one of them
led the polls at one point in time so
that was definitely very interesting to
watch with the conservatives first in
the lead and then the greens took over
with analina bairbach with this drive
for change and then olaf schultz took
over from the social democrats but of
course there's a narrow margin now
between him and i mean lashed but i've
got to say that i think the most
striking point in this campaign was the
deadly floods in august because that
refocused the debate it was more about
content it was about how to tackle the
climate crisis here in germany because
everybody agreed that it is related
those extreme weather events is are
related to climate change and then i
mean lush had committed some mistakes
that will probably hear more about in
the course of the day where he didn't
behave like somebody who wants to run a
country should probably
now polling stations are now open how
much will voter turnout today matter
it will matter significantly just a week
before the election so last week some 40
percent of germans said that they hadn't
made up their minds yet that they were
undecided whether to go to the polls and
then who to vote for and so the smaller
parties will probably gain some votes
but maybe the bigger parties the big ten
parties the conservatives the social
democrats and the greens will also have
managed to mobilize some more voters
which would make it an even tighter race
and so the result tonight at 6 p.m is
really completely unpredictable
political correspondent nina hannah
haser thanks so much
now the buzz about who would replace
angela merkel began in late 2018 when
she announced that she would not be
seeking re-election but campaigning only
began in a in earnest a few months ago
and it has been an eventful season let's
take a look back now at some of the key
moments that have defined this race
boisterous crowds
[Applause]
fuel for the fight
[Music]
i want a higher minimum wage
and hard truths
the climate crisis is happening now and
we have to act now in 2021
twists and turns
it was the most dramatic campaign in
years
armen lashed merkel's chosen successor
began the race after a bruising battle
just to secure the backing of his own
conservative block
the
we have not made it easy for ourselves
because there is something at stake
his rival social democrats crowned olaf
schultz almost unanimously
he entered the race with low
expectations after the party's years of
fading popularity
[Applause]
another cdu csu-led government will cost
germany prosperity jobs and a future we
can't let this happen
the greens chose annalina bearbach to
make the case that their time had come
bearbock positioned herself as the
change candidate and led the polls back
in the spring
[Applause]
on climate protection there isn't one
millimeter between olaf schultz and amin
lachet
that was the worst of the sparring
keep your guard up lash it is instructed
advice he could have done with weeks
earlier
when floods devastated his home state
for lashit an opportunity to demonstrate
leadership
then this happened
as the german president consoled victims
lashit was caught laughing in the
background
the moment seemed to cement public
feeling that he wasn't ready for the top
job
someone next to me made a stupid remark
and i laughed about it that annoys me
that was stupid but i can't undo it
berbock too ran into trouble hit with
allegations she had exaggerated her cv
and plagiarized sections of her book
a pitfall of german political life
support for her dwindled
steady schultz reaped the benefits
though he faced an uncomfortable
grilling over a money laundering scandal
that took place under his watch as
finance minister
his no thrills approach a selling point
i'm applying to be chancellor not a
circus ring master
sometimes it felt like that yet his
message resonated with polls giving him
a comfortable lead
as election day neared faltering lashit
needed a boost bratwurst is the right
thing for the final sprint
more than meet he needed merkel to
revive his fortunes
calling his predecessor to a wet and
windy rally
[Applause]
would continue the course of attracting
new jobs here and making employment
possible
a late bid by a hugely popular
chancellor to turn the tide of public
opinion one last time
and i'm joined now by our chief
international editor richard walker to
look back on this election campaign
richard tell us are germans voting today
for a party or for a preferred
chancellor well of course
the way the electoral system works in
germany and in in many european
countries is that you're not voting for
a chancellor you're voting for a party
and that party then goes to parliament
tries to drum up a coalition and then
a chancellor emerges from that but of
course the three main parties have
chancellor candidates what we've seen in
the course of this election campaign i
think really well summed up by matthew
there is is a campaign that really was
focused very very heavily on these
candidates and it's no wonder really i
mean angela merkel has been in power for
16 years she's been this extraordinary
phenomenon here there are so many
younger voters under the age of 30 or so
who've known no other chancellor um who
are really thinking about this you know
in a completely different way for the
first time in many years
so
essentially what we've seen during the
course of the summer is the voters sort
of kicking the tires on all of these
candidates
um and as we saw in that report
olaf schultz is the one who's emerged as
is is the most popular and the polling
you know many much of the polling around
these candidates really shows that he's
the person that germans seem to trust
more than the other two
but the question is whether that's going
to be enough to get him over the line
and that's where questions about parties
do come in because the social democrats
been very divided for many years there
are doubts about the social democrats so
that's really going to be the question
whether
he is dragged down by his party or
whether the conservatives are dragged
down by their less popular candidate
that's right because i mean as we just
heard all three candidates come with
some pretty significant um baggage how
much have the scandals that we've heard
about
shaped voters perceptions of these
candidates they have very much and the
you know olaf schultz what people often
say about him is he's the candidate
who's made the fewest mistakes
uh and the other two candidates arm and
lashes the conservatives and uh and
elena bearbach of the greens
uh who have suffered uh under the
scrutiny of this election campaign
during the course of the last few months
um we saw that moment in the report
there where arman lashed was spotted in
the background laughing during this
scene of tragedy after these floods that
hit his own state that he governed so
hard
that had a really
sudden and profound impact on on his
popularity ratings raising questions
with whether this person
really had the sort of seriousness of
mind to be chancellor
annalina bearbach has been a different
issue with her it's been really relating
to her relative lack of experience i
mean she's somebody who came up through
politics essentially as a sort of party
worker
um hasn't held any sort of executive
experience before
um and there have been some slips that
she made which we saw in the report
there which have
added to this sense that maybe she's not
quite ready
um so
yeah it's schultz who's emerged as the
person who has made the fewest mistakes
but also somebody who seems steady
um and seems pretty close to the mold of
angela merkel and angela merkel is
bowing out with still the most popular
politician in germany which after 16
years is really an extraordinary uh
thing so
so he's hoping that some of you know
some of the kind of credit that she gets
for just being steady as she goes uh
actually transfers over to him right so
let's talk about um angela merkel both
amin lashed and olef schultz have been
campaigning as as merkel's successor so
how crucial has merkel's legacy been uh
to this election race
well yeah i mean it is the sort of is
the framework in which this election is
taking place isn't it and
she's looked at in two ways really she's
looked at as somebody who has been an
incredible stabilizing influence not
just in germany but in europe over the
last 16 years somebody who has been
effective at managing crises um who has
you know steered germany through the
euro crisis financial crisis refugee
crisis corona crisis it was just like
crisis after crisis
the the critical perspective of her is
that she's been
handling these crises but not really
setting a strategic agenda for the
future
um and particularly on the issue of
climate change which has been very much
at the fore in this election campaign
more than in any campaign beforehand
um she's faced a lot of criticism for
not getting further ahead of the problem
um and
so i think that's really the sort of
the frame that is set for this campaign
and the three candidates are really you
know all in their own way trying to fill
her shoes but
i think what
one quite interesting perspective on
this election is it's it's it's
essentially a question about how much
change does germany want and both lashet
and schultz are pretty closely
associated with merkel having you know
one is member of her party one is her
finance minister member of her
government and elena berbock is the only
one of those three who really represents
a significant departure
much more bold action on climate change
a generational change as well
and it seems that the germans they want
some change but maybe not that much
change
we will see dw chief international
editor richard walker thanks so much
now german president francois steinmeier
has just cast his ballot here in berlin
early this morning he called on all
germans who are eligible to vote to cast
their ballot saying every vote counts
adding that those who do not vote are
allowing others to make their decisions
for them and he had this message for
voters and poll workers
germans are now casting their ballots
around 60 million voters are deciding
who will be elected to the next
parliament
voters are the lifeblood of democracy
and those who volunteer at the polls
perform a service to the community my
thanks to everyone working at polling
places across germany
the german presidency is a mainly
ceremonial position but the president
does have an important role after the
election which is to swear in the new
chancellor and the new cabinet
now the german electoral system is
fairly complicated but there are valid
reasons for that the location where
germans cast their vote their love for
paper trails or how they try to prevent
election fraud here's an explanation of
the ins and outs of the german election
it's the end of an era after 16 years
angela merkel won't be chancellor
anymore
so who's taking over to determine that
germany is holding federal elections
and that's a complicated process but for
good reasons
first thing you need to know germans
don't vote directly for their chancellor
they vote to elect members of parliament
the bundestag they do that every four
years
unlike in many other countries all
german citizens are automatically
registered to vote once they turn 18.
no matter their gender religion or
political conviction
60.4 million people will be eligible in
the 2021 election
every vote counts the same
germans can either cast their vote by
mail or in person on election day
polling places are in schools museums
you name it
poll workers ensure an accurate
efficient and secure process
we are extremely diligent when it comes
to the election process
for instance
we check the election register every
time someone comes in
making sure they're actually eligible to
vote
once that's checked the voter is good to
go
but there are rules
voting happens alone no one else sees
what happens inside the voting booth or
which boxes on the ballot are checked
and no one is permitted to influence the
voter's choice
curtains closed no selfies allowed
on the ballot there is not just one box
to check but two
with the first box germans vote for a
candidate from their constituency
the one with the majority of votes
automatically joins parliament
[Music]
with the second box voters choose a
political party
this second vote determines the overall
percentage each party gets in the
bundestag germany's federal parliament
and in order for any party to enter the
bundestag it has to win at least five
percent of the second vote that's to
prevent smaller splinter parties and
legislative gridlock
there are a few more details for example
the overhang mandates sometimes a party
will receive more direct parliament
seats through the first vote
but this is really complicated so we'll
explain that another time
speaking of complicated no german
election happens without a paper trail
not much is digitized for security
reasons
we have an old school process here in
germany we still use ballot papers not
digital votes
that makes it very transparent for our
citizens
we've had very good experience with that
in these 70 years
but surprise some digitalization has
been happening in the meantime
for the final reporting of votes poll
workers can use for example email
or the good old telephone
[Music]
at 6 pm on election day the first exit
polls will be announced
once the final results are counted we
move on to the next step
remember the election results determine
the relative strengths of the parties in
the bundestag
once the members are set they team up in
coalitions to form a majority
then they elect the chancellor
each step of the process is necessary to
ensure a transparent and accurate voting
system
[Music]